[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain a russian comedy film called
the pregnant spoilers ad watch out and
take care
sergey is a news reporter living
somewhere in russia he and his wife
diana have been trying to have a child
for the past two years but haven't been
successful at the beginning of the movie
sergey is with a therapist telling her
about his problems he says that he wants
a baby so much that he has begun to
dream about pacifiers and strollers the
therapist asks him if he has done the
one thing that is necessary to get his
wife pregnant sergey proudly claims that
they have intercourse every night but
his wife never seems to get pregnant
sergey even wrote his wish down on paper
and ate it one time but that didn't work
either the therapist tells him that his
thoughts will become reality very soon
so he should be careful sergey doesn't
understand what she means but he doesn't
question her on his way to work he calls
his friend and lawyer zora zora has
consecutively lost eight of his previous
cases and is struggling because of
financial difficulties he has two
daughters and is trying for a son again
after talking to him sergey gets to the
set and presents a show with his co-host
somewhere else diana is at an art
exhibition where all the pictures she
has taken recently are being displayed
sergey is late as usual when called he
claims that he is already inside the car
and will be there in only five minutes
but after the call his car is towed away
for being parked in a restricted zone
knowing that his wife will find out
about the lie he ditches the exhibition
and instead goes to a bar with sora as
they talk about children zoro mentions
that his wife is one month pregnant they
are hopeful that it will be a boy this
time because zoro wore felt boots while
making love their family has a
superstitious belief that every time a
man makes love in those shoes the woman
gives birth to a boy that is how zora
his father and his grandfather were born
the next day is valentine's day sergey
and diana go to the place they first met
five years ago they promised to come to
the place with their children someday
before returning home sergey goes to buy
felt boots at night after having
intercourse he takes the shoes off and
hugs them hoping to soon be blessed with
a child when he cannot fall asleep he
walks up to the window and prays seconds
later he sees a falling star ten days
after the incident sergey is in the
studio presenting a program about a
chicken named sonja sonya is a miracle
animal and the rebirth of paul the
octopus she can predict the winners of
football matches by laying eggs the
number of eggs she lays is considered
the number of goals the winning team
will score while reporting the news
sergey suddenly pukes he apologizes and
gets back to work unaware of the real
reason for his morning sickness later he
is at the grocery store buying things
for dinner when the pickle shelf catches
his attention he has never liked sour
things in his life but for some reason
he craves pickles more than anything
that day on the phone zora jokes about
him being pregnant but sergey remembers
his wish and thinks it might be a
possibility that night he finds diana's
pregnancy kit in the cupboard and
decides to test his theory at first he
sees the two red lines on the kid and
thinks it means he isn't pregnant but
after reading the instructions he
figures out that two lines mean he might
have a baby inside of him he takes the
test a few more times but the results
come back positive every single time the
idea is so absurd to him that at one
point he starts laughing at the positive
test hey you're the one that peed on the
stick sergey the next morning he has
pickles for breakfast diana notices his
weird behavior and inquires what is
wrong when sergey tells her they are
about to have a baby she thinks he
cheated on her but on finding out that
he is the one who is pregnant she gets
even more upset thinking that he has
gone insane sergey wants her to be happy
about being a father but diana needs
some time to take it all in that evening
sergey's parents and zora's family come
to their house for dinner sergey takes
the opportunity to officially announce
his pregnancy the family is left
speechless at the announcement they
calmly try to explain that him bearing a
child is impossible sergey storms out
without saying anything leaving everyone
else in an awkward silence his father
blames his mother for doing pregnancy
yoga which he thinks messed with
sergey's anatomy and made him a woman on
the inside the next morning sergey reads
a book on pregnancy and identifies his
symptoms he keeps the negativity aside
and starts to prepare for the child's
arrival on calculating the due date he
is happy to find his child will be a leo
starting that day sergey stops smoking
and eats pickles with every meal he even
listens to children's bedtime stories so
the baby can hear them too with time
diana comes to terms with the pregnancy
and supports him as best she can four
months into the pregnancy sergei now has
a protruded belly he goes to pregnancy
classes every day but pretends to be
there to better understand his wife the
mothers do not question his belly and
think that he is just trying to get the
authentic experience while all his close
ones know about the pregnancy he has
chosen to hide it from the rest of the
world in the fifth month sergey and
diana go to a gynecologist for the first
time however as soon as the doctor sees
that the husband is the one who is
pregnant he refuses to treat him in a
similar way the couple visits many
doctors but none of them accept him as a
patient then one day they come across dr
tikonov who has been in the business for
two months but hasn't gotten a single
patient because he is desperate he
agrees to treat sergey the doctor asks
him to get on a delivery bed but a
stupid sergey cannot figure out what
goes on the leg holder because of his
unique condition he has to be on all
fours for the checkup the following day
at work sergey finds out that zora has
allowed the show to broadcast about his
pregnancy as the word gets out everyone
is intrigued by the man who got pregnant
it becomes an international sensation
much to sergey's annoyance because he
wanted to keep it a secret people in the
streets and the bus now recognize him as
the man who got knocked up they treat
him like an outcast which doesn't help
sergey's mental health he confronts zora
about selling him out for money but the
man shows no regret instead he claims
that he has more ideas that will make
both of them millionaires at first
sergey curses him out claiming that he
won't sell his pregnancy but when he
calms down the money doesn't sound so
bad to him starting that day he goes to
several tv programs and shows as the
pregnant guy he is also made the sponsor
of several maternity products his
popularity grows immensely in just a few
weeks he is surrounded by paparazzi
everywhere he goes and even his family
members are interviewed by many
reporters one day he is at a restaurant
when a gay couple approaches him they
too want to know the way a man can have
a child sergey has no clue how he got
pregnant but he still advises them to
wear a pair of felt boots during
intercourse and do it in a green room in
the next gynecologist appointment the
couple finds out that they are having a
boy outside the reporters surround
sergey again he gets so caught up in
their questions that he doesn't notice
diana being left behind ever since he
got famous he hasn't been the loving
husband that he used to be following
that sergey gets a show of his own where
he provides maternity advice to women
zora makes a lot of money profiting from
the show however the more sergey works
the more he ignores his wife and her
needs for one of the episodes sergey
brings his family to a restaurant and
asks them all to talk about his
pregnancy diana lashes out at the
cameraman and storms off having had
enough of the show after the incident
all of his family members leave and
sergey is left alone for the first time
he realizes that he has let fame get to
his head but before he can fix his
problems a group of religious protesters
protests against him when sergey starts
getting a lot of hate an opposing
broadcasting company sues his show for
fraud they claim that his pregnancy is
just a publicity stunt organized to make
money in the first hearing zora can
barely put his case forward while the
prosecutor impresses everyone with her
thorough research she shows the judge a
file of sergey's personal bank account
that has all the information about the
prophets he has made from his pregnancy
at home diana asks him to stop all the
games and live a normal life as they did
before the pregnancy but an agitated
sergey yells at her in the second
hearing zora brings sergey in front of
the judge and shows his belly to
everyone present there he even presents
the ultrasound results as evidence to
prove him wrong the prosecutor brings
sergey's gynecologist to court according
to her since sergey is the doctor's
first patient the doctor is not
experienced enough for such a
complicated case instead she shows the
judge research from much more
experienced doctors who claim that male
pregnancy is impossible clearly those
doctors have never heard of felt boots
by the end of the hearing sergei seems
to be losing the case one day after an
interview sergey returns home to see
that diana has left him he panics and
realizes how badly he has been treating
her recently the only way for him to
gain her trust back is by giving up the
show hence in the next and the last
hearing he doesn't go to court zora
panics but still gives a heartfelt
speech about sergey being a great mother
everyone in the court claps for his
excellent words but just then the judge
receives a video sent by sergey zora
doesn't think much of it and allows it
to play to his utter surprise in the
video sergey claims that he lied about
the pregnancy and is sorry to everyone
he hurt in the process he also asks for
forgiveness from diana who has always
supported him after hearing him confess
the judge declares him guilty and
charges him a fine of 1 million rubles
everyone who believed in him including
all his fans are disappointed sergey
meets diana at their favorite place and
apologizes for being a bad husband and
using his pregnancy as a tool the two
kiss when suddenly sergey's water breaks
he is rushed to the hospital where the
doctors successfully perform a c-section
on him after the birth sergei tells his
family that he has chosen love over
money they are proud of him for being
brave diana brings their baby and hands
him to sergey for the first time
three years after the birth diana is in
one of her exhibitions that showcased
the pictures she took of sergey during
his pregnancy their son has grown taller
and is playing with zora's daughters a
few months later diana prays to have a
set of twins her wish comes true making
her and sergey pregnant at the same time
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching